[Music]  ladies and gentlemen of NASA this is  Charles Xavier help is on the way doing  space missions now cool we get the  astronauts we bring them home  go heat signatures rising fest  we gotta get out of here where's Jean  where is she  she should be done did you hear what the  kids are calling you  Phoenix hello gene who are you  the better question is who are you  something's happening to me what is  control bad things happen but it feels  good that power destroyed everything  that ever came into contact until you  the taxman fear you and what they fear  we seek to destroy shockula's ooh  a girl dies  she's still upset she's not Jean anymore  that's right  [Music]